nba icon steph curry buys board ape nft
for 180 000 according to block crypto so
here's the story you got the picture up
of our board ape he does not look happy
two-time mvp
steph curry with the shot has decided to
join the board ape yacht club picking up
one of their nfts for 55
eth etha which is basically 180 grand
nfts basically if you're not from are
you familiar with nfts david yes an
unfundable token wow
what's roi
return on investment
is learning
what's opp
you know me
exactly exactly you dealt with opp yeah
you know me well done david you're on
the ball you're already doing better
than you were in episode one
can we get a round of applause
congratulations david so basically
nfts are basically like the half court
shot of investing at this point like
you're just
you're putting it out there it's a hope
and a prayer
maybe it goes in it's worth a three
pointer it's not worth a four or five
point it's still worth a three point
you're just taking a long shot but if
you're steph curry and you're worth 160
million dollars i believe that's his
current net worth
uh that's less than point zero zero
one percent of his net worth okay so
just keeping that in mind so here's a
little thing about this board ape uh
there's a collection of ten thousand
apes with gloomy expressions this dude
don't look too happy
uh his board ape steph curry has blue
fur
zombie eyes and is wearing a tweed suit
okay
this is insane okay what's basically
happening so the digital copy of this
is worth 180 grand
what are we what are we even talking
about right now so usually when it comes
to investing you want to
focus on the company's profits and their
losses or their ebitda or you know if
they have a good marketing plan or who
the ceo is now with nfts you want to
know if the board ape has zombie eyes or
what kind of suit they're wearing this
is this is the current reality that
we're living in but as they say if you
can't beat them join them and steph
curry decided to join them so
uh this i guess these the prices of
these bored apes this guy does not look
happy looks
bored yeah straight up looks
unenthusiastic they've shot up over the
last month the current floor price
apparently bottom price like about let
me get in on the end on the bottom on
the bottom floor the cheapest board ape
nft is going for
25 eath which is
just north of 80 000
if you want one of these bad boys as an
nft oh so that's why you have these 15
year old kids just becoming
multi-millionaires creating these nfts
weird stuff
but it's out there so here's the
takeaway
here's the big takeaway we talked about
this
yeah steph threw in 180 grand on this
nft this board ape but again he's worth
160 million dollars this is a drop in
the bucket for him right this is
this is just one three-pointer and he's
the leading three-pointer off the
backboard exactly he's going to be the
greatest three-pointer in nba history
this is just like one three-pointer
decided to spend on this one nft what
you got we have it here you and i it's
right there the same thing he paid 180k
for yeah we have it right there i'm
touching it there you go
i like to touch it
i just touched the board ape that just
blows my mind yeah this is the current
reality but it's he's got the he's got
the blue one with the tweed suit okay
and he's definitely bored but uh there
was a comment from dawson saying that
apparently steve harvey have the same
one too yeah apparently dustin says
steve harvey has one too
so he's not alone steve harvey invested
in the board ape yeah well apparently
there's ten thousand of them is that
what they said uh yeah
yeah club is a collection of ten
thousand apes with gloomy expressions
okay
so
diversification that's all this is
obviously you save so you save up so you
can invest and then when you can invest
you can diversify you know i'm a big
stock market guy there's people out
there that are big real estate people
there are people that are big crypto
people
i i i don't buy real estate but i invest
in reits real estate investment trust
that you can get into i'm not all in on
crypto but i do have got a couple
bitcoins and i've invested actually in
an nft
platform called ethernet so respect to
them they're doing their thing they
actually did a thing with messi and with
pele they're dope uh so shout out to
ethernet but the point is this
nfts are a thing
yeah it doesn't make sense bitcoin was a
thing that didn't make sense 10 years
ago look at it now yeah so
if you get in on a trend here's my
advice if you get in on a trend you get
in early on an nft you get in early on
bitcoin and you've diversified and
you've saved and you and you have other
investments
buy and hotel
okay there's so many people out there
with regret man i wish i would have sold
my
i wish i wouldn't have sold my bitcoin i
i bought it at 100 bucks and it went
down to 90 and i sold
now it's worth what i don't know as a
filming of this 45 000 where where are
we at today with bitcoin something like
that yeah
i'll tell you right now we got these
things called phones that i could just
take a look at where bitcoin is drumroll
yeah well it's been you see what
happened with el salvador
uh they just basically made bitcoin
legal tender and then the mark the price
dropped uh so it's right about 46 000 as
the filming of the show 46.00 okay thank
you david thank you
big one so anyway diversification so
that's this thing so that's nfts for you
that's steph curry is this a good
decision or bad decision by steph curry
what do you guys think out there bad
bad decision tell us why
he should have if anything
like his worth that like you said he
he's worth so much more than that yeah
160 million i feel like he should have
gone for more like oh you think he
should have spent more on an nft yeah if
you're gonna do something
so that is not a money baby okay yeah
because if you're gonna do something
that in my opinion is
is stupid might as well
go full stupid yeah
okay
no no nobody go full retail no no no
don't don't go
don't go full stupid what are your
thoughts i think i don't think it's a
it's a bad move obviously it's the trend
like you said you gotta get in on it uh
i i saw someone in the comments that you
can't sell this one or something i don't
know if that's true but
why would you be able to sell it i don't
know but it's a cool piece of art
regardless i just think it's weird to
pay that much money for a jpeg that you
and i now have
okay anyway it's a thing now all right
let me let me get let me get in on this
nft real quick let me save him anyways
yeah there you go just save that just
said all right so anyway nfts are a
thing all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro